jean marc bonjour alors le document du
fmi est très intéressant parce que pour
une fois le fonds monétaire
international s'inquiète de la situation
sanitaire pas de la situation financière
d'ordinaire on sait que c'est le
gendarme qui surveille les gouvernements
et les déficits
la france aura évidemment un problème de
financement
oui bonjour absolument vous avez vous
avez totalement raison
premier poids le fmi a confirme que la
deuxième vague de l'épidémie risque de
plomber encore davantage la fin de cette
année et c'est vrai même si le
confinement est plutôt light 1 il y à
des secteurs qui en france où sort tout
de même très abîmées alors on a beaucoup
parlé des petits commerces des bars des
restaurants il ya aussi la culture le
tourisme transport aérien mais deuxième
point le fmi prévoit que la reprise de
2021 sera beaucoup plus regardées lentes
difficiles 5 6% de croissance dit le fmi
si on réussit en 2021 se débarrasser du
coc vide au printemps ce qui n'est pas
garanti mais ça veut dire qu'il faudra
attendre 2022 pour retrouver le niveau
d'avant bruno le maire anticiper un peu
cette reprise dans un premier temps dans
le courant de l'année prochaine alors
troisième point et face à cette
situation et c'est là où c'est assez
paradoxal c'est que le fmi dit que les
gouvernements ont eu raison d'aider les
économies et donne même un coup de
chapeau à la france le fameux quoi qu'il
en coûte d'emmanuel macron vous souvenez
eh bien le fmi va plus loin puisqu'il
souhaite que le gouvernement accélère
encore et continuent à soutenir
l'économie
cette deuxième vague va l'obliger à
renforcer les plans des dettes soutient
et encourage donc le ministre de
l'économie bercy a donné encore plus des
des plus de soutien notamment pour 2021
alors quatrième fois quand on interroge
le fmi pour savoir comment on va
financer tout ça comment rembourser les
dettes parce qu'on a là quand même pris
un paquet rien que pour la france est là
pour 400 milliards mais je ne vous parle
pas de l'europe toute entière le fmi dit
que c'est pas forcément le problème le
plus urgent on verra ça en 2023
peut-être même en 2024 peut-être même
plus tard quand la croissance sera
revenue
en fait les faits me reprends les
raisonnements qui qu'on a fait qu'on
faisait au lendemain de la guerre avec
le plan marcheurs ça remonte à loin
au lendemain de la deuxième guerre c'est
le retour de keynes pour tous ceux qui
ont fait un peu d'économie on met de
l'argent dans la machine pour que ça
puisse redémarrer
est-ce rassurant selon vous à jean-marc
ces deux là c'est rassurant parce que
l'ensemble des pays de l'union
européenne sont quand même dans la même
posture c'est rassurant parce que ça
donne des garanties pour emprunter mais
à des taux très bas comme c'est le cas
actuellement le problème principal que
nous avons c'est la crise de confiance
ce virus paralyse tout le monde les
entreprises les commerçants donc pas de
commerces pas de projet par conséquent
il ya des masses d'épargné kid qui sont
stockés qui ne servent à rien oh non pas
la question confiance moyen de le thème
ça va dépendre d'un vaccin ça va
dépendre d'un traitement
je pense que tout repartira à ce moment
là il restera certes des victimes sur le
carreau mais dans l'ensemble ça a
remarqué un peu d'ailleurs comme au
troisième trimestre de cette année
à la fin du premier confinement quand on
a vu toute la reprise économique fort de
18 % ce qui est quand même fait
exceptionnel entre juin et septembre
ça peut rebondir très vite mais encore
faut dire que le virus disparaisse a
alors est-ce que les incertitudes sur
les élections américaines on est
toujours dans l'attenté de résultats
ajoute justement de l'inquiétude
économique pour les européens
à écouter ça n'améliore pas des choses
que l'économie elle a horreur du hasard
elle a horreur de l'incertitude
elle voudrait de la visibilité alors
l'association américaine n'est pas très
brillant parce que les faits me parle
d'une récession en amérique de 3 4%
cette année compte tenu du coc vider
cette réception est lié évidemment à
l'épidémie et surtout à la politique qui
a été menée par par trump parce que rome
ne s'est pas tellement occupé de cette
pandémie considérant qu'elle n'était pas
relations importantes sur le fond les
programmes de trump ou de bailleul sont
quand même très proches preuves veut
faire une relance par la baisse de
l'impôt belle lui veut une relance par
les dépenses publiques franchement au
niveau économique macroéconomique ça
revient pratiquement au même et a sans
doute des différences notamment dans les
airs comme structurelle sur le climat
l'accord de paris c'est une évidence sur
la santé c'est également une évidente
joe biden a toujours dit qu'il fallait
revenir sur l'eau sur obama fallait
revenir à de l'assistance sociale et sur
le rôle des etats-unis dans le monde
mais là ça reste un peu marginale pour
les européens ça va pas changer grand
chose parce que la tendance lourde de
l'évolution américaine c'est quand même
de se replier sur l'amérique l'amérique
ne veut plus l'amérique ne peut plus
être le gendarme du monde parce que le
monde va être dominée par deux puissants
cela mérite la chine et que l'obsession
l'omission de des états unis ça va quand
même être d'assumer l'adversité chinoise
dans cette évolution de l'europe va
devoir trouver son chemin tout seul et
on verra comment les choses vont évoluer
mais l'europe c'est-à-dire la france qui
a des forces militaires et l'allemagne
cas des forces économiques vont quand
même être obligé de se tourner et
peut-être vers des alliés ont trouvé des
alliés à l'est et pourquoi pas la russie
merci beaucoup jean marc sylvestre
éditorialiste économique 1 pour toutes
ces précisions